there's no other way you can help me
help me
help us because we need it
um welcome back guys we go again um
as you know the huge patreon
if you want that raw stuff unfiltered
uncensored
you know where to go links are in the
description um
in january we're going to be dropping
two patrons
every month first to the 15th the 1st
and the 15th so man like i said if you
guys want that
raw uncut unfiltered uncensored
nasty nasty sign up to that man and yeah
we keep it moving
hope you guys are well jimmy you're good
i'm blessed you
can't um i didn't tell you what happened
to me that's why i didn't tell you on on
the way hearing it
what happened to me this morning okay
scary scene let me pop my monster
oh
[Music]
um so obviously i stayed at j's yeah
oh my neck i'm comfortable today but i'm
tired but i'm good yeah i know
you're not me i'm i'm here i feel like
there's a fireplace just
i'm not saying i feel like a granddad
you know them granddads that are just
sitting on the porch waiting for trouble
to happen
yeah any anything that moves yeah
chilling lounging fam lounge this is a
labrador just there
just stroking it i'm tired um yes
obviously i was like
listen yeah so i say to j's and every
single time i go there
every time i unlock the door i feel like
someone's going to be there on the other
side of the door
i don't know why i always think it yeah
obviously i know the yard is free yeah
but i'm saying i i always think
someone's going to be there and i'm
saying i i never get there
in good time i'm always there like 10
o'clock at 11 o'clock midnight what did
i get this day one o'clock in the
morning
or so half one in the morning yeah so
get there
last night half one and i'm thinking
someone's going to be here i know
they're someone's going to be in bed and
i'm going to disturb them
that would frighten me that would
frighten me it fires me every single
time i go there
but obviously i know that's my issue
yeah
he's done nothing wrong no one's done
anything yeah that's my issue
yeah so got in last night ever since all
right bless did my stuff went to sleep
and um got up this morning and
i messaged him um
last week and i said oh you don't want
to stay there on sunday
is there any time on monday you need me
to be out mine said nah
he said ticket time whatever i said
bless so i was getting showered and
stuff today
firm my clothes are in the living room
i'm in the bathroom my bag of clothes is
in the room
i get out the shower cream towel round
everything um go into the bedroom
and i think yeah went into the bedroom
and left my boxers on the bed
and i'd i put the radio because i was a
bit chilly put the radiator on
put the boxes on the radiator just to
make a crisp toast them up
yeah and i think i put my socks on the
other radiator in the living room
yeah and my jeans and stuff was in the
room everything so i'm chilling
walked through put my boxes on
walked through into the living room to
get my socks my toasty socks
the door unlocks i'm hearing the keys in
the door
and i'm thinking is it jay is it someone
else who is it yeah
fam i can't imagine the paddock
i was stuck i didn't know whether to run
or stay shut
i know i she opened i saw a woman's face
i sprinted into i sprinted into the
bedroom
my clothes are sitting in the living
room
[Music]
i sprinted and obviously i'm bare for
everything and my box is just
[Music]
just pixie laughing about cheeks are
just clapping
at this point i still don't think she
knew anyone was there obviously the
lights were on so she's she'll get she
probably saw so i'd sprint it in yeah i
slammed the bedroom door
but i didn't mean to i just wanted to
close it i slammed it and then out at
example hello
[Laughter]
at this point like a weirdo this is how
you know
i was a serial killer in a previous life
i didn't know whether to say hello or
not
like say i'm hiding
like say i'm hiding
that's so funny she said hello there was
like a four second gap and i was like
hello silence
neither of us knew what to do she said
it again hello
i was like this time i got chad hello
yeah like well go on
go on i couldn't come out
it was too fun it was the cleaner so
she's um
she's going oh are you leaving the
apartment today
and i was like yeah i'm literally
leaving in like five minutes
and she was all right cool but i'll
leave you to it oh my god
what time is this this was not long
before i came to get you
so it would have been about 11 something
yeah but i know he likes his guests to
leave at like ten
oh i've seen it on the note before oh
okay unless he's a guest to leave a ten
so it makes sense
this is the normal time that she comes
that would scare me i've never been so
scared
and you asked him the night before
there's any time that i need to leave by
now this is why i ask
because i'm scared of these things these
things are my nightmare and i messaged
him
expecting an apology yeah yeah i'm
messaging fam
you clearly just interrupted but i was
naked man said did you lips hurt
i had to laugh and just move that's too
funny
oh did you live sir
i ran i wouldn't even expect that
response i wouldn't know what to say
back
that's when we was in the mcdonald's
driver yeah i just laughed and put my
phone down
i think i've had enough of today i've
already had enough of today did you lip
sure
oh fam was she barefoot now no
no no not at all oh that's jokes
thank you for that you're welcome gee
i'm so happy it was the cleaner though
um she was another guest nah sure he
would have he would
keena said he would have told you that
someone was coming in there sure he's
busy though fam
have you ever had a message from him
before just about anything
yeah it's so yeah i know yeah
yeah he's gonna say few and far between
he's hazy he's hazy he doesn't care
it's too nonchalant he doesn't okay his
life's so easy
he just doesn't care so that's why i
never
that's why because he's so hazy that's
why
every time i come there i assume
someone's going to be there because i
think he just doesn't care
and not even in a negative way he's just
life is chill
and in his head he's like what's because
in his head
he's got all the money in all the time
yeah so in his i'm making this up
obviously
i don't know what goes on in his head
the way i see in his head yeah
he's got all the mining all the time
yeah yeah so worst case scenario is if i
went there
because his worst case scenario for him
is always resolved
easily so what i'm saying is if i went
there and someone was there
worst case scenario is i bail him i'm
not bro someone's in the yard you know
and he's like oh my bad and then i'll
get a confirmation email in a minute
from like a new airbnb five minutes down
the road that he's paid for for the
inconvenience and he'll be like cool and
he'll just carry on playing god yeah
his life is easy so that's why i'm
scared
because i i think he's because you're
like
you're a consequential thinker yeah i
know he is a consequential thinker but
his consequences
his version of consequences is so
different to our version yeah yeah yeah
it's minor yeah he said i thought i
checked but i guess i didn't so i
planned you a hundred percent yeah
down the road yeah so
i won't even think if i'm jay i'm not
thinking of that i'm saying you might
have to go back to fueg's's
man said yeah i'll just pat in yours he
would pat on it i know you were he's a
gang guy i know he would he sorts
everything out he does
he reminds me of this is a weird way to
think about he reminds me of
my dad growing up okay in that i think
this is what comes with wealth
in that i'm comfortable when i'm around
him
mm-hmm yeah if anything goes sour not
that i can't handle it myself
but like i remember when i was a kid i
used to go on holiday with my mom a lot
but every single time we went as a
family stuff like it was stress
okay it was stress because
like if anything goes wrong we ain't
going on holiday
if we oversleep and miss the taxi we
ain't going on holiday like if we
like and my mom would always book the
early flight at like two o'clock in the
morning
because it's cheaper and like like i
remember like we got
like we had this like morocco one time i
think it's over
yeah and i hated it i don't know it
wasn't for me it was such a
35 year old person's holiday yeah it was
my mom's ideal holiday as soon as we
landed i knew his mom was i heard that
hardy was so angry
i said this is not for me yeah but
anyway i remember when we landed we got
this out really dodgy like taxi
and it was like a three four hour drive
to the place it was long
it was a long way to get to where we're
going and i remember just thinking like
these are all
like um very carefully budgeted ways to
get the most out of your holiday
but it's like if you miss up any of
these steps your holiday's ruined
so her and my stepdad were always so
stressed
trying to get to like holidays for me
were nothing but just stress
but every time we'll go my dad he
can't fly is that one no worries yeah
flies
lunch time chilly your heart's content
this is fine
we'll get there when we get there and
you can tell that his attitude is
like if we miss the flight we'll put the
next one you know what i mean because
you can
not that he has any intention but
because you know you can yeah the whole
thing is relaxed
and so going on my head we didn't always
we didn't actually go on hollywood
that much but when we did it was just
vibes
i love that i was i i in my soul was
just so
eased going on holiday with my dad
where's going on holiday with mom we
went a lot more
yeah she took us on a lot more her days
but every time i was just like frantic
and stress
i was oh i just remember always being
stressed and i always remember pulling
my
luggage on the wheels and it tipping
into the side of them i'm like
pick it up pick it up come on we're
going to be late now i'm like
i want to dash i think i didn't want to
go now i'm
done here a little hand
oh my god so much stress so much stress
so yeah
jay's demeanor reminds me of my dad's
when i was growing up in that
everything's just fine yeah
yeah don't worry everything's just fine
i need that i found
i need that i saw a tweet today that
said i just want us
citing along the lines of i just want to
spend money and not
look at the price tag something like
that oh yeah
something longer i'm thinking even
though that's such a cliche thing to say
i like a lot of
um musicians about when i say that but
it's something it's not like i want to
waste money and blah blah blah like i
just want to be comfortable just to
spend and just not care like i said
that's it i'll be happy when i book a
holiday the day before payday
oh you said can't wait to ignore the
price tag that was it okay cool i can't
wait to ignore the price tag
oh that feeling the day i booked a
holiday the day before payday
i'm set that is that's what i know i'm
that's what you know you've made it or
if i can make it two months straight and
not check my account
gas gas run me that level of peak
and i'll be happy you man patreon is
there i'll be the best man i can be
do you know what i mean i'll be here for
you man if i'm that kind of if i've got
that kind of money in my account
i'll be here for a while fam easily week
in week
out wherever you want you man you
message me whenever whenever
literally message me wherever i'm
comfortable
i don't care how about i'm about i'll
message you back
ah i've got too much stress right now i
can't afford to do them things
i'm so stressed i'm working like a dog
i'm working like a rabid dog
i'm so stressed i just checked
we've got one little instant messenger
thing at work yeah it's obviously
working from here
everyone's working from home to my boy
and he spoke
randomly he spoke to me the way you
would speak to me
okay and it made me how yeah he doesn't
usually speak to me like that yeah yeah
but like he was off
um he was off for a few weeks suffers
he's actually dread
this is your worst nightmare he suffers
from insomnia oh sure my boy suffers
from insomnia so he goes
days without sleep sometimes days and
then when he sleeps
you can't wake him up he'll sleep for
days as well
what you physically can't wait now and
he's delirious
he's in and out of sleep he's delirious
he's suffered for years i feel for him
guys firm he used to come into a late
half an hour late just sit down just
fed up fed up the days they even began
they used to come in half nine sit down
and just slump oh
i can't nice i used to know them one so
i'd always bring a spare monster just in
case
if he came in slumped i'll just slide
the thing okay
sit next we used to sit next to each
other i remember i trained him up when
he started
yeah he was new and i'd already been
there for like a year and a bit or
something okay
so we were cool man he's a cool guy but
um dash jokes
fab used to come slumped so he's he's
been off a few weeks ago because of his
insomnia and stuff
and i said so like work is so stressful
at the minute
we've got so busy and not not enough
people to manage the world and all this
stuff it's super busy all the time
like i realized i realized the other day
when i'm working i physically don't have
there's not a second in the day that i'm
not working mm-hmm do you know what i
mean yeah i know what you mean i think
this is not a job
this is labor this is slave labor labor
is it literally paid
they're slave labor the company's
getting their money's worth without you
i'm
busy they're squeezing you dry
i'm busy there's not a time where i'm
just like oh you know what i mean yeah
and obviously you have breaks and stuff
like that but i'm just like oh
busy and um you're so busy it's so busy
that
how do this probably this probably it
like resonates from when you're a
bartender
okay it's so busy that when you want to
break
say if you're on a 20-minute break or
something you're counting down the
minutes because you're scared
yeah you've only got three minutes left
christmas um when i was bartending um
what four or five years ago christmas
period
i remember that exact i remember that
exact time so
obviously during christmas period in
hospitality all restaurants are just
absolutely slammed for those who don't
know
um and i used to bartend back in london
when i used to live there in like 2015
or so
um went to i went on a break uh with one
of my
colleagues at the time we went to a bar
just to have like some food and some
drink or whatever
i think we only had like an hour break
we had 30 minutes but we took an hour
because we were tired right there was
there was
a lot i think they had three or four
other bartenders on the bar so we can we
can take this
as soon as we got back the restaurant
was right like everywhere was ramp
oh my god oh my god you have to come
back to this
and he just continued day after day
after every day was a saturday
oh every day is a saturday during
christmas it's not i can't stop
it's fun don't get me wrong but it's
just not easy yeah yeah yeah if you're
not built for this
trust me you're not gonna make it you're
not going to make it after week one
you're just not bro that's how that's
exactly how my work is now from the word
go
it's just manic and when you need to do
stuff it's just like
a manager but oh do you mind waiting to
just calm down a little bit and just
like
it's not it's not gonna calm down it's
not it's it actually
isn't um but anyway yeah i messaged my
boy and i was oh how are you getting on
with everything at the minute and stuff
yeah are you missing like james
literally how you would say it james i'm
just stressed i'm so stressed
and then i'm missing back like bro
same i don't know what to do
it was literally one of our
conversations it was so funny but i was
just like bro
honestly it's long these money to
please help
get
help
we need us more than anything nope i'm
not a beggar but help me
i've been doing this for ages i've been
screaming to top my lungs for
over a year now help me everyone's
always like i can't wait until you get
your job
help me
i get messages every day i love the pod
can't wait to quit
help me
that's what my replies are going to be
usually i'm polite and i'm not going to
help me
appreciate it so every single time i get
messages every day
oh james love the pod etc etc can't wait
you get to quit
i just replied a capital help me i'm
just gonna send him the link to the
patreon
that's it anybody that says to me from
now on
from now i can't wait for you to quit
i'm sending you the link to patreon
that's it because there's no other way
you can help me
it's so funny there's no other way you
can help me
help me help us because we need it
we're in a few years time we're going to
look back and say how i don't
i'm just gonna look back at this laugh
snigger oh
god got the montclair on any summer oh
for no reason
that's hilarious but um oh we're late
where's the fun factory what's the fun
fact let's get started
oh jesus that was hilarious
so fun fact of the day okay so you know
the murray
oh i for christmas is you yes
for christmas yeah that song anyway mary
kerry
she has that song has earned her 60
million dollars in royalties and in the
uk
it brings in 500 dollars every christmas
alone
alone in the uk and that song came out
in
1990 what earlies no
five night four
94 gang they came out in 1994 and i was
like
yes that was a guess
you don't you don't know mariah like
that i don't know right like that i
don't know years like that i don't know
anything
in 1994 and till date that's made us 16
million in royalties
until date in the uk one song one song
till date in uk every christmas
500 bags that's insane
she's never gonna go broke again of
course not
even though i knew she wasn't gonna go
broke again but like that song has
made her that's wild that song has made
her
her she doesn't need to do anything do
you think there's weird that's like
there's just
a selection of like 10 15 christmas
songs
and that's it that's it people try and
make new christmas songs all the time
but there's this
core selection of these are the
christmas songs mariah's in there
you've got um what's it last christmas
oh it's a george
what's the name michael j michael maybe
yeah that's george michael's last
christmas right
here i think it's yeah george uh
michael's supposed to try
the very next day yeah you gave it away
gave it away
that's actually vibe with those lyrics
he's actually mad if you're in
heartbreak
if i'm in heartbreak and i heard that
last christmas bruv i gave you i
literally gave you my heart
and then the boxing day boxing 26 you
gave it away
what you [ __ ] slack
that's absolute arms house um see and
then you've got um
what else have you got um you've got
michael buble is a sign have you seen
the i don't know if
it's actually tweets there's either
tweets or memes saying around
october november time michael buble is
defrosting to do his christmas songs
he runs and he gets paid november
december he gets just paid
and then he chills for 10 months right
i've not seen anything of him
for time now here's george by the way um
the last christmas and then you got the
air that's on do you know that one
that bit rings the bell but i don't know
it's um it always reminds me of the
office
um the show was uh
do they know it's christmas time was
like oh
oh yes yes yes i remember the jingle
bell for the life of me i don't know
um that jingle rings a bell now i can't
remember i can't remember that song it's
a charity song isn't it i think so so
they've got that one and then they got
there's a few others
and then you get if you're lucky you'll
get the destiny's child
you're lucky you're lucky because that
was when you said there's a course songs
that was one of the first songs that
came to mind it was like outward i was
like all right i was popping in my head
already
yeah and then if you're lucky like you
might get a gris brown this christmas
that's not happening that's not i think
that's far-fetched not on the radio
that's not happening
you have to play that in your own yard
you'll have to go to one extra to hear
that
yeah right um that's not happening but
yeah oh my daisy
she's made man she's done she's done
right here she's chilling
fam speaking of you know reminded me of
what i just said about the george
michael thing
ah do you have any guilty do you have
any guilty pleasure
like rom-coms um
not off the top of my head but like i
always say not like i always say but
like i've said on this podcast before
the times when bella goes on her netflix
and it's her algorithm and we watch
stuff on her netflix
the rom-coms bang the rom-coms bang
watch nuttin hill the other day oh
that's a good movie i've not seen that
i've seen that probably since i don't
know i don't think i've seen that in
like me and toby love notting hill i
can't imagine they'd be loving it
me and toby love secret wrong comments
nottingham hill 500 days of summer
days something's great one time we would
it's a great movie
one time it was just me and him in the
house and we sat and watched the entire
eat pray love
i think i think pray love actually bang
was that in grafton yeah we just sat
there and watched i remember
i think i remember coming back home and
you guys told me what just something
along those lines
fantastic fantastic um is that where she
goes on holiday she goes
she does some next things she travels
abroad yeah by herself
and all these things yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah um
so yeah nightingale night now gets me
gets me
fam when my man is uh do you remember
much of it
no not at all i'm just i've not seen it
in you know the premise right
i can't remember it bro i've not seen
like a decade cool let me run you the
premise
gang
um premise he works in a book well he
runs a bookshop
yeah okay okay and then yeah yeah as
soon as you said that it came out a-list
celebrity walks in
and then they just start doing a thing
basically long story short but she's a
[ __ ]
she like she's got a man um because
there's a scene where she invites him up
to the hotel
they go on a date then he walks her back
to the hotel and she's like you want to
come up the way
he portrays the feeling of exactly how i
would feel
if an a-list celebrity is asking me to
come up to the room
um gas just gas
if i run a bookshop fam and the most
famous hoe in the world
is in do you want to come up gasps rugs
gasps thanks i'm sprinting up there so
she says let me clean up
let me go out give me five minutes let
me clean up he goes up fam
knocks on the door and she answers the
door and she's like you have to go fam
you have to go he's like well go on like
he's excited he lips is her fam
everything like well go on
she said my boyfriend's here i said who
i'd opened a door and i opened the door
who's boyfriend
how did you get a stunt he said who she
said i'm so sorry my boyfriend's from
america is here
and he's another famous actor man rolls
in
the boyfriend rolls into the main room
and says oh who's this
and she's like oh and then my and then
uh hugh grant jumped in his
arm room service and then he was like oh
don't you men usually wear like um like
tuxedos and stuff he's like yeah
i'm actually off shift i'm about to go
home i just want to run up and see if
you guys needed anything
gang yeah that's actually really nice
yeah i'll have this this
this and do me a favor clean up these
nasty dishes and take the bin out please
as well
man does it my guy's in the room and
picks it he's
he's staring at the yacht he's staring
at that the whole time
picking up nasty dishes and then the
actor puts
some money in his in his little pocket
tells him
masters what's your name says bernie
says what's your name this is bunny he
says you go bunny
he's a little fiver enjoy yourself
i thought he was a butternut he's
clearing a bin out i promise you know
that will never happen that can never
run with me
that can never run with me if she says
who's this i'm like who you who are you
because clearly you didn't know what was
about the pattern i was about to not
oh i was so upset my dick would
invert so much sam i'd be so livid bro
it's mad it's mad i'd be so livid
it's mad and then he's heartbroken from
the whole movie he gets heartbroken like
four times oh my god
fam he's heartbroken like four times and
then like there's another time where she
leaves
they have like that obviously that
horrible encounter she leaves he's
heartbroken
she's upset about it she comes back to
england to work again
and he gets a tip off that she's working
in some um
tip-off she he gets a little tip that
she's working where she's actually
working in it
in some gardens yeah so he bowls over
there summertime
lavish bowl's over there and then she
sees him she's like wow what are you
doing here he's like i heard you're in
town like i thought like
she's like i'm really really happy that
you're here like there's stuff that we
need to talk about kind of thing he says
go
i'm here for it. he goes and sits down
and they give him um obviously she's
micked up because she's she's shooting a
scene
so she's got a microphone on her stuff
and then um one of the sound guys
says oh do you want some headphones so
you can actually listen while they're
doing the thing
he said yeah gang sits down what does
that do at acting and what in between
scenes
one of the other actors is talking to
her and then he says oh who's that
like handsome guy that that came up to
talk to you and stuff like that she's
like ugh
just a guy from a past life and she
doesn't know he's listening
just she's like just literally just a
guy from a past life i have no idea why
he's here
again man's like he has to pick his
heart up off the floor
and he's like wow wow this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i could never hear that about
me fam
you literally can hear the shattering in
his chest
she's like i don't know why he's here
i would die inside after last time
fam i would drive into the thames
i would drive straight into the thames
fam oh my god and then he picks up and
dips again
and then she comes she comes to his
bookshop
and says like oh like i'm really sorry
about everything etc
she still doesn't know that he had to
say that and then he says to her he's so
polite fam
it hurts me because he's so polite but
he doesn't get angry at all
and then she says oh i just wanted to
know if you'd like do a thing
like if you want to like start again and
everything like that and he says like
can i ask you a question like
why did you say that like when i came to
see you at the
the shoot like why did you say that like
you said this i was listening she she
was
like shocked why did you say that she
was like
obviously like i'm not going to talk
about my personal life with like some
random
actor [ __ ] that i don't even know
like come on brav
and then um he eats that all up yeah he
doesn't he doesn't eat up
too fair he says like all right cool and
then he has to he gets a phone call so
he goes off has the phone call comes
back and she's like ah
like again like i'm really wondering if
we can just start again kind of saying
fam he looks and says
this is probably a decision can i regret
for the mess of life but if it's okay
with you i'd like to like decline your
kind offer it literally i'd like to
decline your kind offer like
i just don't think my heart can take
being with you
like i genuinely don't think i'm built
for it
man says i you're from beverly hills i'm
not you know like it's never going to
work
like if it's all right with you i just
want to decline your kind offer and like
i don't think my heart can take
what you put me through is that i'm sure
would have like a lovely life i just
don't think my heart can take it
like you're just god you're killing me
here
you're killing me here and she's like
cool and then like
she says like that one famous scene
where she's like at the end of the day
like i might live in beverly hills and i
might be a famous actor but i'll handle
that
i'm literally just a girl standing in
front of a boy
asking him to love her she's crying
family
and after all that [ __ ] she's put him
through that one scene
you're just like ah now do a thing with
her fam
she's balling she's bombing being one
females cries
you can't do it you can't say you can't
say no
and she said i'm just asking you to love
me fam please
please i'm sorry for what i've done
please i'm asking
is she back if she's banging as well
she's the most famous home plane i have
she's playing his name
on planet earth she's banging she's
boiling begging me
frown um yeah bro and then he's like i'm
sorry but it's a nah
she's all right bet and then um
when she was at his yard one time so the
post conversation this is
pre-conversation
pre-conversation okay quick rewind
pre-conversation when she was at his
house one time because they actually did
sleep together
at some point in between the parts that
i've said okay in between the boyfriend
bit okay
there was a bit in there did i see do a
thing okay okay so um
he had a painting on his wall uh a print
of like a famous
painting and uh she's like wow i can't
believe you've got that
so um when she came to the bookshop
she's balanced and i love you she
actually bought a gift
and um she said well obviously thank you
very much for being honest with me
this is something that i had my
apartment in new york and i'm sitting in
the apartment and
i thought of you when i looked it so i
thought you might want to have it fam in
her apartment hanging was the original
of that painting that he had in his flat
the original
because when she saw it said i can't
believe you've got that opinion and he
said why is
that doesn't matter and she bought him
the original probably worth millions
she bought it for him he said have it i
said i'm selling my apartment have the
original have the original i know you
like this paint and have the original
and he still said it right bye and then
he went to go see his bedrooms
and told him the whole story and they
were like you're a [ __ ] idiot
you're an idiot chaser chaser and then
the end of the film is just him chasing
he gets that in the end it's a movie
i've seen at least seven times
it's a movie that's my guilty guilty
pleasure that are 500 days of summer
500 days of summer is the most impactful
heartbreak movie it's so heartbreaking
the thing is i think i've only seen that
once or twice because i think you
recommended it to me back in uni days i
think
and i've seen it and i remember the fact
that obviously he's got cancer blah blah
blah you have to shave his head no no no
no
no no no no no you're thinking of 50 50.
i have seen 500 days of summer
yeah it's the same actor though though
yeah yeah i've seen i've seen
50 50 once and i think i've seen 500
days of summer once as well
500 days of summer i remember i remember
that one because
obviously it's the her name is summer
blah blah yeah i know you meet a yacht
called autumn what's up yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah as well i
remember being buff but i just can't
remember
the one scene i do remember is when he's
going through like the good times with
her it also shows
the bad times with her so always does
the rewind thing between the good and
the bad and it always goes to what day
in the 500 days it is
but the best scene in there is the um
expectations versus the reality scene
that's the one that's the scene i was
talking about where he says the good
side yeah expectations reality yeah yeah
yeah when yeah
he said they've been offered like a year
and then they go to
one of their colleagues weddings in a
different city and he bumps into her
is it wow i never seen each other in
ages and he's been going through a
heartbreak without her
and then they dance at this wedding they
have drinks at the wedding their gas
and he's thinking raw like we could
probably get back together
like this could be on the table she says
i'm having a party in my apartment
rooftop party in my apartment i remember
you should come next week you should
come through
and man's like bet rolls through gets
suited a boot it rolls through
yeah and um
and it shows the expectations in this so
he thinks expectation side he's gonna
roll up there
she's gonna give him a hug he gives her
the bottle of wine she's gassed
um oh no he brings her
he actually brings her a special gift i
actually think he brings her the first
edition
of her favorite book i think if i
remember i might be making that up
but he brings her a gift and his
expectation is going to give her to
she's like oh
my days broth like wow that live
like how could you even find this all
this stuff she hugs him etc they drink
she introduces him to her friends and
then like they
get on like crazy and then like
everyone's getting a bit more drunk and
they go off into a corner and they start
lips in and all this stuff
like that's his expectations and and
alongside it exactly the same time is it
what actually happens
and he goes up there she gives him like
a [ __ ] hug when he arrives
she introduces him to the friends while
she he sticks in with the friends and
while she [ __ ] off and does
other stuff for the party and stuff like
that and he's kind of stuck there he
barely gets a chance to talk to her
he finally gets a chance to give her the
book and she's like oh wow
and i think she like says thanks and
then like get cracks on and then later
on while he's drinking by himself
drinking by himself looks over and she's
showing off her engagement ring to one
of her friends
bro he cries and runs off
he cries and runs into the street
just running he cries runs off
i wanted to cry with him ah joseph
gordon never goes
through it in 500 days of summer me and
toby love 500 days of summer
we love that movie it's a great movie oh
my god i've already seen it once
it's the best that's how that's torment
that's torment mandem go through it we
actually do man
go through it people don't give us the
recognition we deserve them
when we go through heartbreak are we
going to throw it bro
we know we do know we go through it
that's why these men are always it's
actually mad now i think about it
all the messages that we get we've never
had a heartbreak one from a girl
all these simply like soppy
like what do i do about this like and
we're always like
man up what are we doing leaving them
yeah never did they come from a girl
they always come from guys
hmm i don't know what to do shall i go
back to actually should i do this should
i do that
women just cut you off women will just
cut you off first mistake you're gone
cuz
i don't need to ask for any advice
you're gone you're gone
it's true boy days wow this is the game
is the game is the game man
it's true g um i think i've got a fan
request actually for you
hit me i've got lows in the dms
jeez louise
cool so man said
hey man just here to ask for some advice
there's this girl i've been messaging on
and off for about eight months
we were gonna [ __ ] like two months in
but i couldn't get hard and flopped
i remember reading a bit of that and i
stopped because i knew it was gonna come
up on this
but continue cool i remember reading
that bit
uh so yeah we're going to follow two
months in but i couldn't get harder and
flopped
i went out with her two times after the
flop
i really like her and don't know how she
feels and so
feels and so i do you think
i i don't because i don't want to miss
read it but i don't know
it's wrong it's janky i already know
it's janky
right she feels and so i do you think i
should okay so do you think
i should ask her how she feels and tell
her how i feel because i
think she could be wife material i've
done things with lots of girls but never
felt this way about a girl before
what was i just saying uh what do you
think i should do by the way i'm 17 year
olds and i'm a virgin so this would be
my first beat
they're always 17 and they're always
virgins they're always 17
and they're always virgins love the pod
by the way
keep up the good work man thank you bro
thank you brother thank you
big man listen yeah
um
first beatty flopped that's tough
before we resolve this
you can't really recover from that like
the day after that's hurting you for a
while that's haunting you for a while
i'm not taking my boxes off for a week
after that do you know what i mean first
ever that's pressure
that's when you need precious getting
yeah that's pressure no one needs
no one needs whether it be the first
first last whatever no one needs that
no one needs that kind of pressure um my
it's hard for me because i've been in
your shoes in the fact that i've not
gone up
and i think i've said it on here it was
with um my ex at the time back in the
day back in uni times
um obviously you know it is and there
was a time where obviously we were
together and i wasn't a virgin
but there was a time where i was at her
place
and i said to her oh just take your guns
because i just want to
[ __ ] you i just want to [ __ ] you
she got undressed before me cuz and she
helped me get undressed
took my boxes off limp wow
i don't know what i think i've said it
on here before i don't know what
happened
i just couldn't get hard wow i think i
don't know i think i was over i must
have been over aroused or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that
inverted youtube theory i was gone i was
way past the
cusp i was gone i was gone i just
i just had to pack my [ __ ] and leave oh
really yeah that's mad that yeah what
could i have done
had do you know what happened from then
oh i
was still boyfriend girlfriend yeah did
you address it did you just move it
funny thing is i don't remember oh okay
i don't but i will never forget that
do you know what i mean i just don't
remember what we if we addressed it
after obviously i'm assuming we did i
like on my walk home like message yeah
you know women difficulties women always
say it's fine it's not
don't patronize me cuz bro
strangely enough all the hell i've had
in uh
sexual relations in my life i've never
ever not been able to get hard
unless i've been way too drunk yeah and
then i would just say i'm way too drunk
like i can't get up cause i'm too drunk
like to me that doesn't embarrass me
because i'm just like i'm hammered like
there's nothing i can do um
yeah i've never had an occasion where
like i've not been able to get hard
because i get hard easy i got
easy that's never an issue the thing is
soda wise i don't know why that happened
but there has been there definitely has
been times though to be fair that when i
when i've been like close where i
thought am i going to get hot do you
know when like maybe it's from round two
or around three
okay yeah those are i'm not familiar
with those yeah true true or maybe it's
like a
i don't know maybe it's cases you've
been in russia but in a while or stuff
like that or maybe it's kind of like
how to explain it so yeah because you
know like me i like spontaneous sex
i like sex on the sofa i like sex on the
floor like
i'm not a massive fan of like betty bye
time sex
yeah betty buy
like we have sex at 9pm every day like
in bed
covers over yes yeah same position same
position i'm not a fan of that
so obviously i've had girlfriends in the
past whatever whether where there's been
times where
um it's just routine routine routine and
then we can be getting into it
and like we're talking maybe it's like
30 seconds before i'm
i'm about to head in there and i'm soft
as can be
i've had those ones okay i've always
managed to get up before
i ever try and put it in but like
there's been times where i've been even
i've
had a facebook vagina and i'm like i
don't know if i'm gonna get hurt
like i'm i'm this is so normal now yeah
that's what we do every day
and i'm just like bro
and yeah and i'm just like i don't think
i don't know if i'm gonna get harder
i've definitely been in those situations
but this is not what my mouth's talking
about
first b first b i was poking through my
boxes before we even
anywhere near it first b i was
solid [ __ ] me off i'll never forget it
she sucked she sucked me off as if to
say
you know when ah
how can i describe it how can i describe
it
like you know when let's say you're
drinking a
drinking a drink from like a bottle or a
straw or something and
it dribbles down a bit you try and kind
of suck it back that's the way she
tucked me off
it was so and she was just she was all
over it yeah again
and i was like oh okay
but yeah um right let's help this guy
out okay yeah i forgot
we got lost in our own source like we
always do ah
okay give us give me a recap again sorry
so sorry he's 17 years old yes
he's been talking to this girl for a
while yes um they got into it
and it was the opportunity for the first
beat yes he couldn't get it up
yeah and they've moved on from it he's
been out with her twice since then
but they haven't brought it up
whatsoever they could brush it under the
rug okay and i'm assuming he's
intentionally avoided getting in that
situation again
just out of fear of it happening again
but that's my assumption but i know they
haven't been in that situation since
and he's asking us should he just go and
try again
should he move on completely or should
he just talk to her about it no he
i personally think because i'm outside
the situation obviously it's easier for
me to say but if i was in this situation
i wouldn't want the advice
but the best thing for you to do is try
again um because at the end of the day
in my life in my opinion anyway
at the end of the day she's obviously
still thinking about this
this mishap and so are you even though
you guys aren't addressing it
it's gonna have to be addressed because
if you lock whatever you've got going on
with her
we both know the reason why you're gonna
lock it do you know what i mean so you
might as well have the conversation or
you might as well not have the
conversation and just try and go again
yeah so we can just rectify
and be like okay bomb it was a one-time
thing i was nervous etc it was my first
time
maybe she's a virgin as well who knows
and then we just crack on yeah but just
crack on because
it's happened to you now it's probably
going to happen to you again in the
future you know i mean like where you're
just not gonna go hard
and it's just live it happens and i
don't know why
i don't have reasons i don't have
answers rather but you should just try
again man
especially if you feel like you fancy
this girl yeah bro especially i would
i would happily have the conversation as
well i would just say like yo
because i hate when there's an elephant
in the room
the pressure of an elephant in the room
that's undiscussed i can't handle it
we have to i have to address the
elephant in the room like first
and yeah and you can make a joke out of
it man
and just be like cool so we both know
what happened last time
i'm not gonna lie i'm trying to bust
nuts
and i just want to do this yeah i want
to do that i want to do this yeah i want
to do that to you
and like last time was a flop and i
don't want us to think that that's just
the thing yeah
yeah yeah so let's let's please let's
just go
let's go let's go again just don't put
any pressure on yourself and just
be here for it yeah because yeah i would
personally i agree either just try again
or have the conversation
personally for me obviously you could be
like
or you could be like me i don't know or
you could be like neither of us but for
me
i wouldn't be able to just go again
without conversation but yeah it would
be
it would be more pressure than i needed
going in again without having a
conversation
because now i have to perform now i have
to be flopped the second time as well
that's what i'm saying so if we have the
conversation even if i flop the next
time
we can still talk about it whilst it's
happening yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't
have to get dressed and look
and go yeah we can talk about it and be
like okay okay i need some help here
yeah you just
get that throat gorin
because saturn sun's going on yeah i
need your help
i doubt she's going to be like oh no
like this is dead i'm sure she'd be like
gang or whatever in it
if you need to surprise out more from
here i'm here for it
i'm sure that might you're more likely
to be able to address it in the moment
if it happens again if you've already
had the conversation yeah if you don't
have the conversation and you dive
straight back in and it happens again
you have to lock her off you can never
speak to her again
you can never see her again literally
you can never see her again if it
happens the second time and you guys
haven't discussed it
you have you you have to part ways
delete the number block on everything
and move on
ah and then you're gonna have that on
your back for the rest of your life
it was like me with the johnnies when i
was first trying to start with johnny's
and it flopped
and i never had the discussion of any of
the ads and it flopped the first time it
flopped the second time
and i couldn't sort these guns out and
they were too tight and they weren't
working and then it affected me for
years
for years you would never forget it if
till now it sticks on my head you would
never forget exactly and that's
all because i was too scared to actually
have the conversation with you at the
time
and that was nothing to do with like not
being able to get up or anything that's
because
johnny wouldn't fit if anything that's a
bonus but at the time i was stressed
so yeah if i would just have the
conversation block right these jollies
are fitting bruh yeah like you might
need to help me out like
something needs to happen yeah she's
like whatever johnny what's that
don't use it then and everyone would
have been happy but no
i was too stressed i just kept it still
i was too embarrassed and that was when
i was 17 as well
so i know it's tough but i would
definitely have to compensate if you
think she's if you if you're trying to
do a thing with this girl long term as
well
you need oil of course they can you just
have a situation i have to be necessary
especially if it's long term like jimmy
said yeah it's gonna have to be a
conversation today yeah man
good luck with that yeah
good luck with that it's tough man it's
tough being a guy
as hard as it is being a woman it's
tough being a guy's especially in those
scenarios because
a woman can always go you can always go
live your body will automatically
you're going to get wet regardless like
if i touch your vagina twice you're
getting wet yeah and even if you don't
there's things we can do
exactly if i can't get hard from there's
nothing we can do nothing we can do
apart from finger at my tongue like but
yes that's foreplay foreplay is always
great don't get me wrong but
without the tool i might as well
be yet with a strap-on do you know what
i mean it's pointless good shout out
actually with the finger in the tongue
if he yeah definitely talk to her
actually definitely talk to her because
if you have the opportunity to talk to
her
you can say at least you can address the
fact that it might happen again
and just say worst case scenario if it
happens again you're i'm just gonna eat
out
she's gas no matter what she's probably
had that before
she's probably never had that he's
probably never done it before though
exactly
so she can be like win win i hope you
can't get up
because i heard that's fantastic
ah yamin pum is
it's a delicacy it is a delicacy is this
your delicacy
for the first time i did not think so
first time i was like
i gave it nah i'm trying to remember if
because i i don't think i ate the girl
out who i lost my virginity to
i think it was a girl after i think
and i remember i think i've said this on
the pod as well um
i remember doing it and after we [ __ ]
and everything because yeah i think she
asked me probably if i'd done it before
and i said no i've never i've never
eaten a girl out before but your boy was
watching porn
so he knew the thing do you know what i
mean right um
so after i ate her out and then like all
sex was said and done whatever
sex was all said and done rather she was
like are you sure you've never even
eaten anyone out before i was like
mother's like i hold my hands up while
he no
i held that spice was like you did well
i was like gang thank you johnny sins
help me out
that's jokes that's jokes came through
with the virtual coach
oh my god gang um but yeah i wasn't
about it the first time i was not about
it
but i was i think the reason i wasn't
about it was because i didn't
the first time i didn't do it because i
um
[Music]
was like like we said like engulfed in
the moment i did it because i was like
cool like i should
try this okay okay okay okay and it was
like
yeah it was more like very like uh
mechanical like cool
i'm going to do this now no i didn't say
that i'm going to yeah right now but i i
know
yeah like yeah it was it was weird it
was weird
and it was just like cool man and i
think she probably because
she could tell like i wasn't necessarily
massively about it she probably wasn't
necessarily about the whole experience
was not live
but then after the first time it was
normal sailing yeah
these days delicacy caviar
should we wrap this one up all right see
you man see you man next week